so the Guardian first reported on
Cambridge analytical and the harvesting
of Facebook data back in December 2015
that was a journalist called Harry Davis
and a lot of what we know now we knew
then and Harry went to Facebook and
answered it all sorts of questions and
he did not get answers subsequently
other journalists came they also wrote
about this so Hannah's grass edger in
Switzerland and with our shorts with the
intercept myself for the observer and we
did not get answers and that is what
these tech platforms do and have gotten
away with they just deny they evade they
evade in our case they actually kind of
threatened and intimidated us before
publication and then when they do
acknowledge that there is an issue we
get this incomplete disclosure so sandy
mentioned today that there was a news
story yesterday in the New York Times
where we're learning that their answers
that Mark Zuckerberg gave to Congress
were incomplete I think we can if they
weren't actually misleading I think we
can say that they were incomplete and so
which is why it's so important what
you're doing here because I think you're
probably the one institution which has
got the authority to be able to stand up
to protect Giants and I think you are
the one body that they are actually
scared of
[Music]